you know what's funny if a guy if a girl
was saying no no no no and a guy went on
to a girl that would be assault but we
get so much privilege as women like
imagine if a guy went in starts twerking
on a woman and like pours water
everywhere I just you know I just want a
point not that I mean I don't think
they're traumatized by it I'm just being
honest but like
I just want to point out the double
standard and how women can behave badly
and not really have any real consequence
till at some point her looks are gonna
go and this isn't going to be cute
anymore it's real it's not gonna be cute
um it's it I mean it already isn't but
you know just imagine like an old lady
doing that you'd be like what